bonsoir massimo nava merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france quels sont
les scénarii envisageables ce soir dans
tout les prévisions sanquer à la fin mai
mais s'il comptait réussir à avoir la
majorité absolue mais en tout cas la
possibilité d poursuivre son
gouvernement et récupérer un peu des
consensus soit l'intérieur du sénat
comme hier à la caméra l'assemblée
nationale a déjà la majorité absolue et
donc de résoudre la crise et dans
l'espace des deux trois jours et les
problèmes c'est le résultat politique
les conséquences politiques de cette
crise et s'annonce encore compliqué
parce qu est en fait celui d'un dans
l'alliance des gouvernements affaiblis
et là les vote l'abstention mais en fait
la rupture de la majorité de la patte de
l'ancien présidente du conseil matteo
renzi a évidemment provoqué un choc dans
l'opinion publique et elle naturellement
d'un dans la cohésion de gouvernement là
tout le monde concernent qu est ce qui
peut se passer exactement il ya ce que
des élections législatives anticipées
peuvent elles être d'actualité
normalement les femmes tombent des
élections anticipées étaient beaucoup
évoqué notamment à la droite dans le
strain doigt la lega lombarde à monsieur
salvini malfaiteurs ressemblant
prospective franchement très loin et
très très très difficile à poursuivre
d'abord parce que tout le monde sait
qu'avec les systèmes italienne aucune
partie peut avoir à un vrai et est
fiable et majorité donc on entrait quand
même dans les périodes des comptes des
confusions et des complications en bus
dans les mois de juin prochaine
comment semestre blanches c'est-à-dire
les périodes où était impossible dé
tenir des élections anticipées pasquet
en vue de l'élection du président de la
république est selon la constitution
italienne
on peut pas faire
organiser des élections dessoude relais
l'assemblée avant six mois
et en plus dans leur empreinte hay al
alagi ventes en italie
donc je pense que tout l'intérêt des
italiens d'abord et aussi évidemment de
la majorité c'est dé tenir
j'ai je voudrais aussi vous souvenir que
pour les votes de confiance c'est
suffisant la majorité simple
sauf les lois des bilans où elle est
nécessaire de la majorité absolue mais
sans ce système italien mais mais
comment expliquer justement cette
instabilité politique chronique en
italie où les gouvernements se succèdent
et changent très souvent c'est dit pas
de bêtise depuis 1946 l'italie a connu
tout 25 premier ministre je crois et
plus de 70 gouvernement litige vérité
politique mandela day ça c'est que
d'abord nous on à l'assemblée nationale
qu'il est senna qui ont presque les
mêmes pouvoirs et avec un système
électoral très compliqué très
proportionnelle donc c'est très
impossible presque est un parti gagne la
majorité absolue est aussi et toujours
forcer à avoir un gouvernement de
coalition est évidemment mettre ensemble
dans la même démarche à pau si vous
voulez les partis démocratiques débauche
le mouvement 5 étoiles les centristes
les libéraux les catholiques l'insomnie
et ça c'est vraiment très très compliqué
un peu plus aujourd'hui comme dans tout
le pays
la pandémie un fait des dégâts énormes
et tous les gouvernements commis des
erreurs on adhère étape dans l'estrie
mission de vacins des aides à les
personnes âgées à l'eal est catégorique
nous oublie plus démunis de cette
pandémie
tu es donc chaque leader politique
chaque force politique a toujours un peu
l'intérêt à faire un peu de démagogie
parce que c'est très facile de dénoncer
les frissons de pouvoirs publics et
et des gouvernements face à cette crise
énorme qui a touché la plupart de la
population avec des dégâts énormes plus
à l'italie vous savez ce n'est pas de
toucher avec l'airé cordes triste décès
merci massimo nava d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialiste au quotidien il corriere
delle à faire